Stephen King's it is a complex story in
which a lot of things happen and at
times things get a bit confusing but
don't worry about getting lost in the
story we're here to explain everything
you need to understand the full story of
the movies made from the classic novel
possible spoilers ahead 2017 it's didn't
get into the backstory of its ancient
antagonist outside of implying that it's
been around for a long time but
thankfully King's original novel goes
into much more detail
it's the shape-shifting being that often
manifests itself as a creepy clown named
penny wise has actually been around
longer than mankind itself
it's an ancient cosmic being that's
billions of years old that originated in
another dimension outside of our
universe known as the macro verse in
prehistoric times it came to earth on an
asteroid landing in the place that would
millions of years later become Derry
Maine it hibernated until humans
appeared and then began a cycle of
awakening roughly every 27 years to feed
on them it can take on any form but it's
favorite eventually became that of
Pennywise the clown its true form known
as the dead lights is apparently so
trippy it'll drive you crazy Beverly
Marsh managed to glimpse them in the
first film and make it out with her
sanity though doing so did render her
comatose for a time as strange as
Pennywise is its mortal enemy is even
more bizarre a giant turtle named
michurin who hails from the same place
as Pennywise
the turtle is a being of creation rather
than consumption and actually vomited
our universe into reality when it had a
stomachache so you know compared to that
a shape-shifting death clown isn't all
that weird after all in the 2017 film
the story of it picks up in 1988 when
seven-year-old Jorge Edinboro ventures
out into a rainstorm to play with a
paper sailboat that his older brother
bill made for him the boat gets away
from Georgie and journeys down the
street until it ends up in a storm drain
after chasing it
Georgie attempts to fish the boat out
only to discover that uh-oh
there is a clown in the storm drain as
well though Georgie doesn't know it this
clown is the evil entity Pennywise who
has just awoken from his most recent 27
year slumber Pennywise entices Georgie
to come into the sewer promising not
only to give him his boat back but also
by telling him that an entire circus is
waiting for him in the sewer
Georgie gets a little suspicious but he
still wants his boat back
so when Pennywise offers it to him the
kid goes for it and for his trouble
Georgie gets his arm bitten off
don't you just hate mondays in the film
Georgie gets dragged into the sewer and
the town eventually moves on assuming
that he simply drowned bill however
seems determined to find out what really
happened to his brother the losers Club
is the name of bills group of friends
who eventually go head-to-head against
Pennywise along with bill the club's
original members are Richie Tozier Eddie
kasparek and Stan URIs with three more
members added as the story progresses
Ben Hanscom Beverly Marsh and Mike
Hanlon everyone in the group is an
outcast in their own way the gang bonds
over the fact that they're all losers
hence the group's name and they spend
the entire summer together following
Georgie's disappearance the previous
fall though they aren't all aware of it
initially a number of the losers Club
are also suffering from some sort of
private trauma
Beverly's father is abusive and
domineering not to mention creepy as
hell are you
Eddie has an extremely overprotective
mother who makes him believe he's
constantly sick Mike is an orphan whose
parents burned alive an event he
witnessed firsthand and bill of course
is still mourning the disappearance of
his little brother for which he feels
guilty a few of the losers are more than
just friends or at least they hope to be
over the course of the first film Ben
and Bill developed feelings for Beverly
then is the first to develop a major
crush going so far as to write Beverly a
love poem from a secret admirer
that really cherishes the poem and comes
to believe bill wrote it and as a result
develops feelings for him much to Ben's
chagrin even after discovering that Ben
was her mystery poet after he revives
her from her dead lights induced coma
with a kiss Beverly is unable to dismiss
her feelings for Bill and at the
conclusion of the first film Beverly and
Bill kiss in it chapter two fans can
definitely expect this love triangle to
increase in importance in the book
following the losers clubs initial
defeat of Pennywise the group all go
their separate ways in the ensuing 27
years until Pennywise returns a number
of them go through major changes but
none greater than Ben he physically
transforms from an overweight kid to a
wealthy and attractive man and Beverly
certainly notices when the gang reunites
as adults after exploring some residual
feelings for build that includes
sleeping with him even though they're
both married
Beverly determines that it's Ben for
whom she really cares and the two of
them finally end up together at the
novel's conclusion in addition to
Georgie
other children go missing in derry such
as Eddie Corcoran and Betty rip 'some
this leads the losers to believe that
something is amiss in their town before
becoming a loser himself Ben begins
researching the town's history and finds
that violent deaths and disappearances
seemed to spike in the town every 27
years at a rate of 6 times the national
average he was just great
kids are worse way way worse
but it's not always penny wise who
directly causes the killings his evil
influence infects the town whenever he
awakes causing violence and hate crimes
to spike in the novel the role of town
historian belongs to Mike rather than
bet Mike first learns of the town's
sordid history from his father who kept
a photo album filled with pictures of
dairies history that consequently
features a number of photos of Pennywise
some from many decades earlier as an
adult Mike is the only loser to stay
behind in Derry after the rest of his
friends part ways becoming the town
librarian and furthering his knowledge
about the most messed up little town in
New England no one who dies here ever
really dies one by one the losers draw
the attention of Pennywise it appears to
each of them separately first appearing
is one of their worst fears before
showing them it's clown form bill sees
Georgie in his basement Mike sees
burning bodies trying to escape a
building Eddie sees a grotesquely
deformed leper Stan sees a painting of a
ghoulish flautist come to life Beverly
is sprayed by a geyser of blood from her
bathroom sink Ben is chased by a
headless man in the library and Richie
sees a maggot-infested doll of his own
corpse some of these encounters happen
differently in the book but the upshot
is the same they soon discover that each
of their hallucinations have one thing
in common
a terrifying clown the losers quickly
deduced that this clown must be behind
the child slayings and dairy
Pennywise also appears to Henry Bowers
the vicious town bully who torments the
losers but instead of eating him
Pennywise uses Henry as an agent of
destruction so why go through all the
trouble of turning into a bunch of
creepy monsters well any wise needs to
eat humans to survive that greatly
prefers to devour children its reason
for this is pretty simple
according to penny wise flesh tastes
better when it's seasoned with fear and
children are easier to scare than adults
that's it that's why penny wise
shape-shifts into whatever its victims
are most afraid of and why it usually
stalks them for a time before killing
them it wants them to be as scared as
possible before making them its next
meal in the book it compares the process
to assaulting meat
always let it rest afterwards so relax
is becoming tender and juicy after a
frightening encounter with it and the
abandoned house on niebolt streets most
of the losers lose interest in trying to
fight penny wise and just pretend like
nothing ever happened that changes when
Beverly is abducted by the clown which
rallies the other losers to come to her
rescue they follow her trail to the town
sewers then enter its domain to search
for Beverly then they take care of that
mean old clown once and for all or so
they think after the traumatic
experience of defeating it the children
of the losers Club come to the
realization that they're growing up fast
in the original film after realizing the
importance of what they've just gone
through bill suggests the losers make a
blood oath to swear that if Pennywise
ever returns to Derry they'll return to
defeat it again he finds a piece of
broken glass cuts each of their palms
and then they all stand in a circle and
hold hands the scene essentially
concludes the film in the book it's
stand rather than bill who initiates the
blood oath but the sentiment remains the
same in it chapter two and in the novel
all of the losers eventually move away
from Derry except for Mike twenty-seven
years pass and all of those who left
gradually forget the events of their
childhood but Mike having remained in
Derry remembers everything and when
children start disappearing in the town
once again he calls upon each of his old
friends to return to Derry and fulfill
the oath they made 27 years earlier the
losers all find success in their adult
lives but despite their professional
successes some are still feeling the
effects of their childhood trauma but
none are holding on to more trauma than
Stan after receiving Mike's call Stan
immediately remembers the harrowing
events of his childhood not willing to
face it again he draws a bath and slits
his wrists writing it on the wall and
blood as his final act the other six
losers reunited a Chinese restaurant in
Derry the first time they've all been at
the same place in 27 years after
learning of Stan's death and after
Pennywise makes its presence known by
taking on various disgusting forms in
the group's fortune cookies they declare
their intent to kill it once and for all
in the 2017 it film Henry
ours appears to die after Mike shoved
him down a well this posed a potential
problem for the sequel because in the
book Henry goes on to play a key role as
an adult
well the ends of the book can rest easy
because Henry survived his fall the
adult version of the character has been
cast for the sequel and he can even
briefly be seen in the movies trailer
after his final confrontation with
losers as a child
Henry is committed to a mental
institution for killing his father in
the book penny wise again uses adult
Henry as a weapon against the losers it
frees Henry from his incarceration and
tells him to kill the losers club after
siccing Henry on the losers fails to
eliminate them
Pennywise hatches a new plan to kill the
group in the book Beverly's abusive
husband Tom arrives in Derry looking for
his wife so he can kill her Pennywise
takes control of Tom and has him
kidnapped Bill's wife
Audra who has come to Derry out of
concern for her husband Tom brings her
to its home in the sewers as a lure to
bill once there it reveals its true form
to Tom and Audra killing Tom and
rendering Audra comatose the lure works
and bill heads to the sewer for a final
confrontation with it but he doesn't go
alone Ben Beverley Eddy and Ritchie all
accompany him these five members of the
losers Club proved to once again be too
much for it and after it battles them in
the form of a giant spider the losers
kill it for good by besting it with a
sort of mystical battle of wills
[Music]
Easter Bunny Eddie dies during the fight
and the rest of the losers all again go
their separate ways
save for Ben and Beverly who leave Derry
together eventually they all forget the
saga they've been through again check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one